Hello!
My name is Jay Smooth and as you may have
guessed from the title of this video, over the next 12
weeks I am going to teach you about Media Literacy.
First, allow me to introduce myself:
I’m the host of New York’s longest running
hip-hop radio show the Underground Railroad, a
media commentator on TV, radio and interwebs,
and I’m best known nowadays for my video blog
Ill doctrine, where I dissect the latest news and yell
at people about being nicer to each other.
So what exactly is media literacy?
We’re gonna talk more about this in our
first episode, next week, but here in the preview
I’ll at least tease that definition.
For our purposes, in this course, media literacy is
“the ability to Access, Analyze, Evaluate, Create and
Act using all forms of communication.”
We’ll break down what that means throughout
this series, but for now I just want to drive home
the fact that media is all around you.
And living in a saturated media environment,
it’s important to understand how to digest all
of that content.
Like, how do I know if a piece of media is
trying to manipulate me?
Spoiler Alert: It probably is.
Or, how can I be sure that a piece of news
is fact based?
Don’t worry, we’ve got some tips and tricks
for you.
We’re going to explore the breadth of media
that surrounds you in your daily life.
We’re going to look at why it’s created
and what its goals are.
We’re gonna look at everything from popular movies
to propaganda to your date night text messages.
Media literacy skills are about everything from
navigating popular culture, to being a better citizen, and
even being a better communicator in your everyday life.
Which may or may not include yelling at people
to be nicer to each other.
There’s a lot to cover and I can’t wait
to get started.
I’m Jay Smooth and I hope you’ll join me on
this journey with Crash Course Media Literacy.